a question for both of you to start
because I love highlighting the value of
a good scene partner and you have many
in this movie can you each name a Time
on set when a scene partner gave you
just what you needed so you could crush
a tough scene or maybe reach something
in your character that you wouldn't have
been able to without them I you know I
mean uh uh you're going to hate my
answer um you liked acting with yourself
best no uh I I I it was a scene um uh
between Doris and Fritz in the bedroom
yeah where um um for the first time he
gets an
inkling that there's something changing
in their relationship and in their
marriage and um
uh the way Sean staged it right
um Mora had her back to me and so she
could couldn't see my face mhhm but it
was the way that she was saying what she
was saying to me and and and the the the
the the the the inherent message of of
her words um uh that were devastating um
to Fritz and because you know I think he
was a guy who only loved one woman in
his
life
the film didn't the scene didn't make
the final cut so you know uh uh what can
I say to you except um if DVDs ever come
back then maybe no I I I I I I I it
didn't it didn't make it in but but you
asked me which scene it was it was that
scene in the bedroom between I mean
there was another scene in the bed they
cut all the bedroom sced uh that was
earlier on where she's kind of begging
him
to go to church cuz for a while he stops
going to church and and that's a very
very very good example of another scene
which sadly did not make the final um
you know uh Fritz was a religious man um
but Fritz also uh began you know to to
question you know his faith and and not
so much the existence of God but why God
had singled him out for so many
tragedies what did I ever do to deserve
do do you know what I mean to to have
you know so many to to to to lose to
lose my my my youngest son then to lose
you know you know David who was the the
the the kind of the star you know what I
mean of the family at that juncture and
then to have you know you know my my son
Mike you know you know you know end up
in a in in a coma and and and and and
you know there were there were he
had
um for a long
time had an almost antagonistic
relationship with with with God and that
might sound like a very like uh uh
unusual thing for a religious man you
know but but but but it wasn't for Fritz
you know you know he believed in God he
believed he was a good Christian and he
didn't believe that he deserved these
tragedies and and and the scene that
Moore is referring to um is one in which
she um encourages me you know to kind of
put all that I'm describing behind me
and come to church with her and with the
family and and and and and I decline and
it it was a that was another
don't you go oh there no initially right
in initially or or know but then what I
was going to say there's a nice
interplay between us because it was a
real um it was it was playful it wasn't
like you have to come to church and no I
hate God they were she was trying to
charm him and I I just thought the scene
was really light and it was about a
fairly serious subject matter for her so
I I really enjoyed that but then then
you go to church I end up going to
church but if you if you recall there
was a scene there was a scene in which
in which initially you go to church with
the boys andit and Fritz stays home to
watch the Dallas Cowboys because he was
a big Cowboys fan because Fritz had been
a football player before he became a
wrestler you know what I mean and then
later do you know what I mean she she
persuades me you know you know you know
to go and and against my kind of you
know what I mean hey yeah you don't want
to go I don't want to go you know and
and not because I I I'm I'm not a
Believer it's because of all the reasons
I described a few minutes ago so those
were so two sort of wonderful SCS look
you know
[Music]
um the the edit is the edit the edit is
the edit but knowing those scenes aren't
in the film it will make people go and
buy whether it's on DVD or digital the
deleted scenes are there and it winds up
enriching the experience of the story
after the fact so they'll still probably
live on or at least I'm trying to speak
that into exist right now it's it's in
in a sense it informed our our
relationship as actors so you know
sometimes things will happen in
rehearsal or whatever it's not in the
finished product but it it feeds the
whole you know it it informs the
performance
you know sometimes whether or not it it
makes the final cut or if you're in the
theater like I say there's stuff you'll
try that's not going to end up in the
production but it it helps to create a
cohesive sort of chemistry with the cast
oh without a doubt to to build on that
and to end here I'll ask you each
because there's only so much of this
family story that could be fit into a
2-hour and 10-minute movie that anyone
can take is there seriously is there
anything you learned about the real
Doris and the real Fritz that isn't seen
on screen or heard via dialogue but you
held tight to it and now we could feel
it informing your performances uh for me
the answer to that would be that I think
that when Doris leaves Fritz after you
know a 40-year marriage that um it was
an absolutely devastating thing for him
and uh I don't think he ever recovered
from
it we don't see it in the movie uh but
um
uh but you know he died a few years
later and I think he died uh
lonely and uh filled with
regret my heart sad I mean really
anything for you Mora yeah I I think
what a personal choice I made that I
didn't tell anybody about I believe that
Doris starts questioning her faith way
before she admits that she's questioning
her faith I think I just
think and maybe that's just how I was
like at this point I don't know I think
it's might be a charade for her or the
last thing that she's hanging on to but
I think before she told anybody else in
the family I think there was probably a
lapse in her because she felt betrayed
by God too she just wasn't allowed to
say it it' hurt more to rap right now
but I get to keep you for a little
longer so we can wrap this conversation
I will say thank you very much your time
yeah thank you so
much